mais oui mais oui ou non aller à ta
place à ta place oui ça c'est dire la
fin ce n'est encore qu'une élève mais à
onze mois mais où elle se débrouille
comme une pro rester à sa place ne pas
courir auprès de ses congénères et
marcher au pied un enseignement complet
pour faire d'elle un bon chien guide
agnès sa famille d'accueil suit ses
progrès depuis ces trois mois est arrivé
mais où est donc au mois de février
juste avant le départ en vacances au ski
donc elle a commencé à arriver trois
quatre jours et les parties discutent
avec nous la montagne
et en fait depuis le début tout se passe
vraiment très très bien
c'est vraiment une très bonne élève
enfin moi celui un peu maman subjugué
par les capacités et les compétences
qu'elle peut avoir
eh bien oui tu viens le rôle d'agnès
dans la formation de mai où elle est
essentielle c'est elle qui lui apprend
les bases de l'éducation et la
familiarise avec d'autres environnements
la futur chien guide est suivi par un
éducateur bientôt mais où elle passera
six mois à l'école de buc
elle sera ensuite remise à une personne
déficiente visuelle en fonction de son
caractère
la personne qui s'occupe des dossiers
des déficients visuels et qui les
connaît arrive déjà à faire un peu à
celui-là il irait bien cette personne là
on va essayer en attendant qu'il
enquille en éducation va essayer en
termes de rythme en terme de finesse que
ça passe et puis apprendre à gagner 0
mise notre problème à l'heure actuelle
c'est effectivement que nos déficients
visuels
ils sont en attente de deux ans environ
avant d'avoir un chien guide
parce que l'éducation prend énormément
de temps chaque année les chiens guides
de paris re met 45 de leurs compagnons
encore 120 personnes sont en attente
ces chiots n'ont que quelques mois mais
eux aussi deviendront de véritables
guides pour leurs futurs maîtres l'école
recherche des familles d'accueil pour en
prendre soin